[Musique]
la donne
ouais sharon a pas d'accord yannick est
avec toi mais encore fait défaut tout
d'abord il faut se couvrir et demandez
aux gens dans la rue qu'ils y croient
c'est fou hein à quoi manuel valls et
kelly ah ouais alain delon et valérie
ouais quoi plus crédible son coup de
coeur pour valérie il a remplacé pato
chant et rihanna et cyril direction la
tunisie elle s'installe avec cyril mais
il joue gros intérêts de la péter parce
que le bloc même le gall est ce que je
fais là alors moi j'ai chopé c'est pas
mon délire pour rappel aussi ingénieux
jeu alors je peux la rappeler je pense
que je pourrais être son délire bah oui
mais en vrai ah oui donnez-moi 0 s'est
jamais ou alors j'ai pas du tout monde
et c'est pas du tout mon délire aimait
beaucoup de tongs suis au courant quoi
crâner tongs à 900 tongs
j'avais ding dong feng shui c'est manon
mais jeune femme du monde elle est en
tout cas les paraguay est vrai que la
ville avait un problème a toujours
palestine vous et les strings et où les
gens quoi et nuit vous aimez pas
beaucoup déjà ça dépend du pied mais bon
je plaide jean michel non je passe mon
tour entendu un abat lui à sans rigoler
c'est une salade tomates oignons
merci monde sofi devant sophie bambou
non mais là un vrai qu'il ya des choix
ma dans cette ligue si je vous dis 20.4
ça fait combien mathématicien c'est ce
qu'il fallait pas rater à la télévision
française ces dernières 24 heures mais
très très très vite royal
[Musique]
au casting du film le grand bain de
gilles lellouche était en promo à cannes
et dans ce casting à benoît poelvoorde
qui est très en forme en interview merci
d'amener avec vous ce ce très beau
casting benoît poelvoorde salut benoît
bienvenu
effectivement ce qui est chouette c'est
qu'on a on a mélangé ces familles a pas
de chapelle et ses 10 à ce salon le film
encore joyeux et je me dis non ils sont
vraiment vous êtes hors compétition aux
pennois vous êtes hors compétition je
suis le premier désolé je suis mais oui
mais oui benoît vous êtes hors
compétition va continuer un autre
supporter a préféré de l'om rené
malleville et l'a voulu faire à paris
sur la victoire de l'om de m'asseoir
mais quand on lui donne le pari à mon
avis risquent de supporter madrid un
bagage quoi si on gagne tu tournes coca
fraises pendant un mois
[Musique]
tout le monde se demandait ce qu'était
devenu quasimodo ne disent les vents
l'aperçu où j'étais aujourd'hui on
n'aura pas les refaire
les journaux
on en est ou de l'interview sur la
croisette sandero maintenant on n'a pas
fait les scènes de groupe tout de suite
c'est un abri à ceux à se maîtriser les
uns et aux interviews des purs guillaume
avis très harmonieux qui s'est passé
entre les acteurs de raconter site et
enfin notre is a commis l'irréparable à
gauche ils ont pu la retrouver au marché
des poudres saga de la famille qui vient
hollande on les emmène ici j'ai fait
tous les marchés
[Applaudissements]
la moto c'est la fête j'ai ce matin je
les comprends rien ah bah oui nous aussi
merci bon est-ce que je parle de mes
petites astuces make up alléger la tête
à tête est sûre il ya des astuces
m'écoeure alors je vous dis contre les
cernes
j'ai vu un stade aux caries non tome est
d'honorer délecter des crèmes pour les
mains
exactement utilisé au cinéma pour
rajeunir les regards non ce soir est un
vrai bon maître de cuba
c'est pas le problème si tu crois qu'il
va pas faire un autre haut lieu
enfin si tu te dis non et si en fait si
merci tonton si j'avoue j'ai regardé les
six boutiques et à laurence la donatrice
sur la mer j'ai dépassé des milliards la
plus innovants l'émission elle a investi
dans des cours de théâtre laurence et
elle compte les rentabiliser je vous le
dis on c'est simple elle surjoue tout ça
pue le césar cette histoire allait rôle
combien de centimètres perdus grâce à
notre portée comme jade 6 9 cm à redon
19 centimes à 10 cm ou d'un de taille
d'autant près de largeur là nos regards
des 10,9 cm non 10 centimes à 19
centimes à 10,9 cm mais c'est un truc de
fou
une participante de maison à vendre ces
demandes sont à nyon grâce à stéphane
plaza c'est cool mais elle va devoir
consulter un psychologue peut-être juste
après c'est super joli ici
enfin tu peux a tiré quand même bien
dans ta chambre n'était pas arrivé
depuis longtemps et on a découvert une
nouvelle application pour tout à faire
chez vous ça permet de mettre là sa
photo dans des films on a essayé avec
les copains autour de la table gilles
verdez déjà très crédit vent se plier en
superman d'aller voir
car il est bon ouais
la marche on apprécie le visage
d'isabelle aussi dans twilight en place
bella
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attention cyril peut jouer dans avengers
et iron man che guérilla et rona un
bâtard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas non plus ça va c'est pas ça va
ça va se faire a tellement tout vos
émissions que depuis six ans je suis
devenu archi fan j'ai ouvert un skyblog
et tout est depuis la rentrée vous
animez à faire confie j'ai retenu
quelques trucs à faire conclut ce qu'on
aime vraiment dans cette émission c'est
que les candidats ils sont à votre
écoute ça hyper attention à ce que vous
dites savent que vous êtes la patronne
sur le plateau ça file droit en tête
mais n'oubliez pas vos adresses
merci c'est tout droit je prends juste
maintenant c'est le cadeau euros ça fait
quand même le plus sur cc topolanek
sophie toujours proche de vous
journaliste sophie vous savez exactement
où chacun se trouve à un moment ça mais
aussi technologiques
voilà très bien c'est difficile beaucoup
philippe en direct de la wii n'est beau
manteau six offices et vous êtes
parfaitement bilingue je suis pas sûr
que fait ça se disent vraiment comme ça
en anglais station avoir c'est lucile
qui vous propose des exercices justement
spécial after viste en français c'est
quoi ce concert
enfin si vous posez des questions un
petit peu évidente sophie mais c'est
normal vous lui perte or on connaît ça
et ça fait comment de tri bouteille ses
bras la ram meeting et en français mais
à tricoter avec ses bras
sans une bonne ambiance sur le plateau
vraiment une bonne ambiance et même si
vous êtes la patronne parfois vous
prenez un petit tacle de vos coachs pas
si vous en rappelez pas prête de revenir
faire du yoga c'est sûr mais si on
cumule tous les exercices on devient
comme vous avec une alimentation
équilibrée et la motivation mais ouais
au moins comme moi en tout cas
[Musique]
les revenus totaux des franchement vous
cartonnez l'après midi et ça m'étonne
pas aussi parce que l'émission juste
avant ça commence aujourd'hui
mais tellement une bonne ambiance sur le
service public sur la chaîne qui a plus
qu'à suivre en fait c'est juste avec
faustine bollaert voilà c'est une
émission de témoignages une vraie rampe
de lancement de bonne humeur
on a pris des appels à témoins des
émissions à venir pour les semaines qui
arrivent on va bien se marrer je pense
sur france 2 une minute de bonheur aux
serbes par émission sur c'était un très
bon moment passionnant vraiment merci à
finir vous aussi venez témoigner dans ça
commence aujourd'hui votre conjoint vous
acquitter pour la baby sitter de vos
enfants
suite à votre rupture votre excellent
géant diffusant des vidéos de vous vous
étiez en couple depuis plus de vingt ans
lorsque votre conjoint vous à trouver
votre famille vous rangez votre famille
a volé en éclats vous êtes en situation
de surendettement
vous êtes tombée amoureuse d'un prêtre
[Musique]
dans les ans
geagea cherche un alibi pour espionner
ses colloques dans la villa aulas ne
choisit pas l'objet très crédible c'est
tout un art d'espionnage
il faut toujours avoir entre et itran
attends je vais récupérer un livre merci
matériaux france acquise or si lost
heroes qui porte le nom le moins
rassurant quand tu vas lui rendre visite
parce que parfois ça fait un petit peu
peur
on en parle avec votre invité ostéopathe
emmanuel piquemal une bombe et chaud
ça faisait longtemps s'amuse à inverser
la coupe de cheveux déjà on aime aider
avec ses rites ça nous fait marrer
on commence avec vos deux coaches faire
conclut 230 euros on est tous les deux
est-ce qu'à 230 euros on peut faire une
affaire pour tourner tous les deux
est-ce qu'elle 230 euros peut faire une
halte bouffe habiter dans un ruisseau
citation on apprend et quand on gagne
ici on ne touche pas s'empêcher de voter
assez similaire amis allemands
[Applaudissements]
les fausses couches dans un instant mais
avant ça dort c'est dans le monde il ya
deux catégories de personnes ya ceux qui
regardent le 12 13 de france 3 et ses
convives y coule et vous l'avez compris
je fais partie de la première catégorie
dans le 12 13 de france 3 on avait une
vieille connaissance soutenir les
herbiers regarder en est content de le
revoir
françois hollande à la cool les herbiers
ont au final c'est fabuleux
il est content la vitesse et nudes
khalil a dû quitter le plateau
la démission pour la plus belle des
raisons on a une pensée pour
l'animatrice qu'elle vous combler
pendant une heure derrière faire une
sorte de je sais pas comment appeler
sentiment c'est un instrument qui fait
beaucoup moins de bruit
je veux recevoir un sms qui me dit que
ma femme attend la maternité
c'est sûr je n'aime pas ce que j'ai dit
sur les trois modèles écoulés
félicitations c'est merveilleux la
partie les tarifs des 4 vérités de
caroline roux et lieu beaucoup trop tôt
pour son invité du jour
à tel point qu'ils nous allons faire là
bas bruit la plus longue au monde est en
l'occurrence refusé ce projet
ferroviaire ça veut dire que vous
voterez pas ça veut dire que je sais que
je suis sur l'intitulé même jeu
c'est dans le 12 13 de france 3 quand la
le présentateur il est resté bloqué sur
ses fiches en retour plateau grâce à nos
caméras il va fera rouge
on sait pourquoi on regardera ce retour
d'une météo plus favorable oui pardon
qui inquiète à ce contact et tu as été
dans la rue exactement avec des fausses
couches de magazines et vous aux sorties
avec les grands de ce monde parce que
vous êtes des grands de ce monde ne
rajoute pas demander aux gens ce qu'ils
en pensent et tout simplement c'est
parti c'est quoi en plus les y croit
vous allez voir on prend on enlève ceux
qui propagent la manuel valls et kelly
pour la première sachez que je vous ai
demandé qui est un petit peu en
difficulté un indice s'est glissée sur
le les loups un indice est glissé sur le
plateau je peux pas vous dire de qui
s'est dit d'accord
manuel valls est que ces partis qui
revient d on est donc parti à votre
rencontre avec nos fausses couvertures
et notre porte à clément commence avec
zacop manuel valls et kelly et relève
des députés au merde
elle est fraîche et à l'ouest prennent à
qui on dit un tournage pour nous un peu
non as emmanuel bex et elle y met qui
elle est ce que tu connais manuel valls
le président oui à ton avis pourquoi
elle avec lui un bon marché les
présidents depuis combien de temps deux
ans je crois non
ensuite on est à alain delon qui
auraient tous quittés voilà valérie se
quittaient pas que je suis là we should
away non non ça me choque vraiment fait
pour l'argent c'est l'argent des bijoux
n'avons plus à nous ne lui a pas donné
une petite place donc du coup forcément
elle essaie de nous dire aller au plus
je passais par alain delon je pus vite
grimper je pensais ça que son style bas
lieu que pato je crois marché je crois
qu'il ya pas vraiment de pronostic à
faire un pouvoir déjà son espérance de
vie à lui apprendre à la durée du
mariage est alors de tabac avec rihanna
direction la tunisie et les gens il est
beau mais vas-y et bien vous la percée
du gia lâm poids
on y traite un merde la pauvre but d'
iphone mini bus le fun qui parlent
anglais cyril hanouna déjà non non ça va
pas du tout ils vont pas ensemble
pascal était jeu elle est jolie mais lui
il est pas beau du tout c'est un petit
meneur cas merdes et ça c'est pas
possible je suis en jambes pourquoi
alors bas pour
pour
peut-être pour le sexe anal cyril
hanouna sebag on crie rihanna ici à la
noix son ensemble pas vrai
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]